and then you get cory booker who and you
gotta love
mr potato head over here he didn't just
bring his angry eyes he brought his
concerned eyes
and um and cory booker if there's one
person who can make kamala harris look
not rehearsed it is it is cory booker he
makes her look spontaneous and joyous
cory booker is the most rehearsed
politician i have ever seen in my entire
life
he is perhaps the most irritating
politician about i mean and i watch
politicians for a living
this dude is as irritating as itching
powder in your eyes i mean this guy is
just
nails on a chalkboard irritating here is
cory booker
who is very upset that a vote is even
going to be held on amy coney bear you
can tell he's upset because he uses both
his upset eyes
he brought his angry eyes he takes out
his upset eyes pops him in
blinks a lot very upset cory booker and
then he just repeats things over and
over
he repeats beetlejuice until michael
keaton randomly appears
in the well of the senate here was uh
cory booker being obnoxious
what is going on in america today in the
midst of a deadly pandemic in an
ongoing an election having a rushed
supreme court
nomination hearing is not normal
and we cannot normalize it people are
voting right now the american people
should decide
the american people should decide the
american
people should decide
i will not be voting to confirm judge
barrett's nomination
okay either cory booker is the most
emotional person who's ever been in
american politics or he's completely
unemotional and he's kind of a sociopath
and uh and i sort of feel like the
latter because every time i'm so
upset the american people should decide
tinkerbell should live
amy coney barrett shouldn't be on the
court clap until tinkerbell lives cory
clap clap spartacus clap it's a
spartacus moment tinkerbell's living
we're doing it
yeah it's not happening amy coney
barrett is going to the court so
congratulations
corey booker meanwhile dick durbin is
saying that it is
it is a self-serving proposal this is
the senator from illinois
uh who again once called american
soldiers akin to pol pot i remember this
uh senator durbin says it's self-serving
for republicans to fill the seat after
all they didn't fill the seat with
merrick garland
yes because they weren't going to vote
for merrick garland because they
disagree with his judicial philosophy
senator durbin here's durbin again doing
this routine we can't win the vote so
there shouldn't be a vote
people had already begun casting votes
and my republican colleagues marched in
front of the cameras
looked down at their shoes dutifully
reversed their positions
and lined up obediently behind their
leader again
it gets down to this the american people
do get an election year voice regarding
a vacancy on the supreme court or they
don't
in 2016 senator mcconnell said give them
a voice
now he says don't give them a voice it
is a shameless
self-serving venal reversal okay
um just a note it's also a shameless
self-serving venal reversal that you all
said that merrick garland should get a
vote and now you say that amy coney
barry should should not
pat leahy most famous for having a cameo
in uh the in the batman movies
i heard senator leahy from vermont
saying the same thing they're breaking
their word they're breaking
you guys are pledging to to pack the
supreme court guys
and kill the filibuster i think that
them quote unquote breaking their they
didn't give their word that they were
not going to vote on a republican
nominee they said when the parties are
controlled
parties control different branches in an
election year then you should wait for
that to be decided by the american
public i think it's a dumb principle i
don't think you have to vote on anybody
you don't want to you're the senator of
the united states
but democrats are trying to hang their
head on this
we shouldn't be holding a hearing three
weeks from a presidential election
when millions of americans have already
voted
now when doing so requires that
literally half of the senate
goes back on their word think of that my
republican colleagues literally
half of the senate had to break their
word
contradicting every argument they made
four years ago
about the american people needing a
voice
during election year vacancies okay so
screaming at the sky and whining about a
perfectly traditional process again
there have been more than a dozen i
think the statistic was close to 20
people who have been nominated
during an election year and usually when
the parties control the same branches
they when they control the executive and
the legislature the person gets
confirmed
when a different party controls the
legislature from the presidency they do
not get confirmed it is that simple
facts don't care about your feelings and
it's a fact that the ben shapiro show is
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content